une nomination qui ne passe pas inaperçu
celle d'agnès busan à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé sur le réseau
social twitter de nombreux membres de la
classe politique évoque un scandale
selon eux ce nouveau poste à l' oms
c'est une récompense loin d'être mérité
agnès buzyn recasé à l' oms opération
d'exfiltration et pognon joli scandale
agnès buzyn nommé halo oms quelle
mascarade après avoir menti minimiser
l'épidémie est sauté du navire pour des
ambitions personnelles
la voilà récompensé d'une belle
nomination grâce au copinage et allante
reçoit macro nist belle opération de
recasement d'agnès buzaglo ms décidément
un scandale en chasse un autre
et dire qu'on nous vend dès la fin de
l'ancien monde mais quand il ya de la
gêne y'a pas de plaisir
après le ministère de la santé busan d
art paris il existe un monde où la
nullité la défaite à l'acheter seront
récompensés ou les irresponsables se
couvrent les uns et les autres et
défendre leurs privilèges
c'est l'oligarchie et c'est avec cela
qu'il faut en finir
plusieurs polémiques entourent agnès
buzyn pour sa gestion de l'épidémie de
kovy 19
tout d'abord sa déclaration fin janvier
2020 alors que le virus a fait son
apparition en chine
le risque d'importation depuis ou année
modéré il est maintenant pratiquement
nulle puisque la ville est isolée les
risques de cas secondaires autour d'un
cas importé sont très faibles et les
risques de propagation du virus dans la
population sont très faibles alors que
l'épidémie se propage échos les français
se ruent dans les pharmacies pour
acheter des masques
la ministre déclare qu'ils sont inutiles
elle sera par la suite auditionné par la
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
le co vide 19
elle y assure avoir anticipé la gestion
des stocks de masques
ce qui a également marqué sa fin de
mandat c'est sa démission du ministère
de la santé fin février 2020 en pleine
crise du coronavirus elle remplace alors
benjamin griveaux candidats la
république en marche à la mairie de
paris
éclaboussé par un scandale sexuel le
mois suivant dans un entretien au
quotidien le monde ces propos font
l'effet d'une bombe
elle explique que la tenue des élections
municipales est une mascarade en raison
de l'épidémie
quand j'ai quitté le ministère je
pleurais parce que je savais que la
vague du tsunami était devant nous
depuis le début je ne pensais qu'à une
chose au corona virus on aurait dû tout
arrêter c'était une mascarade
la dernière semaine a été un cauchemar
j'avais peur à chaque meeting
j'ai vécu cette campagne de manière
dissociée accusé d'avoir quitté le
navire en pleine tempête
agnès buzyn s'est aussi mise en retrait
après son échec aux municipales à paris
je me demande ce que je vais faire de ma
vie avait alors confié l'ancien ministre
de la santé